MALE SPEAKER: Good afternoon.
Thanks for coming out this
afternoon for this edition
of Talks@.
Today's speaker is David Burkus.
His latest book, "Under New
Management," which many of you
have but Steve doesn't, reveals
the counterintuitive leadership
practices that enhance
engagement and drive
performance.
He's also the author of "Myths
of Creativity: The Truth
About How Innovative
Companies and People Generate
Great Ideas."
I'm personally hoping
we have some time
to talk about that today.
He's a contributor to the
"Harvard Business Review"
and "Forbes."
He's also been featured in
"Fast Company," the "Financial
Times," "Bloomberg
Businessweek," and "CBS
This Morning."
He's been a featured and keynote
speaker at many Fortune 500
companies, including
this one, as well as
Microsoft and Stryker.
He's a TEDx speaker.
I've watched some of his video
on the YouTube and TED channel.
He's also been at
South by Southwest,
and he's also done
speaking at the US Naval
Academy and the Naval
Postgraduate School.
He's an associate professor
at Oral Roberts University,
where he teaches and lives with
his wife and their two boys.
So please join me in welcoming
David to speak here today.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID BURKUS:
Actually, you're never
supposed to say I'm excited
to be here as a speaker.
This is, like, coaching
rule number two,
right after they tell you
don't actually picture them
in their underwear.
They tell you don't say
you're excited to be here
because what's the alternative?
You're really mad and ticked off
to be here, which is not true.
I'm legitimately excited
here mostly because one thing
that I guess I normally
leave off my bio,
but for years [INAUDIBLE]
is that I grew up
in Groton, Massachusetts.
And I haven't been back in
Boston in, like, five years.
And so it's really
exciting to me
to actually finally
be back here.
So thank you for having me,
just because you got back
to my hometown, which is great.
I have a thesis.
And I saw a couple
of people flipping
through copies of the book.
And you probably don't know it
yet because for some reason,
unlike a good researcher,
I put it at the end.
Mainly, I was writing
the entire book
and I was having
these conversations
with a variety of different
corporate and entrepreneurial
leaders.
And one person during
one of the conversations
said something that I
thought was brilliant,
and so I decided I should
put it in the book.
And I made the mistake
of putting it at the end.
And I say it was a mistake
because it's really
sort of the guiding thesis
for the entire book,
and it's this-- great leaders
don't innovate the product,
they innovate the factory.
And I realize how
dangerous it is to say that
at a place like this, right?
But what I mean is that
innovations to the factory,
factory being a metaphor
for all of our workplaces,
precede innovations
to the products.
The innovations that we make to
how we work and where we work
precede our ability to innovate
in any other situation.
And this has been true
for hundreds of years.
This was true when a
young junior consultant
first approached
Bethlehem Steel and said,
I can turn around your problem.
Now, you probably never
heard of Bethlehem Steel.
That's OK.
But their impact resonated
for hundreds of years.
See, this young
junior consultant
wanted to help
Bethlehem Steel compete
with bigger captains
of industry,
like Carnegie Steel and a
variety of different places.
And so he came with
what would later
be his world-renown stopwatch.
And he begin to study the
production process at Bethlehem
Steel, and he begin to find
the optimal way to design
that production process.
And then he started
training the labor force
on how to conform to
that one best way.
And he revolutionized the
entire history of manufacturing.
He made it possible in the
early 1900s for a variety
of different industrial growth.
Some of you are
nodding your heads
because you've
figured out who it is.
But if you haven't
yet, I'll give you
a famous quote that
sort of embodies
what he believed about the
role of management and labor.
And it was this--
"The duty of enforcing
the adoption of standards and
enforcing this cooperation
rests with management alone."
He was big on the idea
that you had management
and you had labor, and it was
best to keep the two separate
because labor was
too dumb to know how
to do something the right way.
So it was management's job
to teach them how to do it,
labor's job to just do it.
This man was Frederick
Winslow Taylor.
How many of you remember
Frederick Winslow Taylor?
So I teach undergraduate
management classes.
And so we have to spend, like,
the first two weeks talking
about the amazing contribution
of Frederick Taylor,
and also why he
was totally wrong.
Frederick Taylor was
definitely right for his era.
He knew that you had to
reinvent the factory in order
to have all of the
innovations we needed to grow.
That was very true,
and his impact
resonated for a
really long time.
Taylor would write a book called
"The Principles of Scientific
Management" that
is still in print.
It's been over 100 years.
"Principles of
Scientific Management"
would travel the globe.
It would be translated into
a variety of languages.
Actually, Taylor's
grandson remarked one time
that he went to Japan
to visit executives
and they bowed
very deeply to him
just because he was the
grandson of Frederick Taylor.
Taylor's devotees
would start a magazine
about scientific management
that would morph and change,
and you know it now as
"Bloomberg Businessweek."
It got its start as a
fanzine for Frederick Taylor.
He also joined the faculty
at Tuck, Dartmouth's business
school, one of the
first business schools
in the country.
And he revolutionized
Bethlehem Steel and a variety
of different industries.
We got where we are
right now because of what
Frederick Taylor did in
the physical factories.
But where we are right now
is not the physical factory,
doesn't look like it.
I have not been to many
actual manufacturing plants
with food that's good.
So it is not a physical factory.
We've moved from a physical
factory to an idea factory.
The products usually
aren't made by brute force.
The unit of energy or where it
lies is not the bicep anymore.
It's the brain.
We designed it in our heads.
We moved from a physical
factory to an idea factory.
But we drug Frederick
Taylor with us
from the factory to the office.
And a lot of the ideas inside
of management theorists
are based in Frederick
Taylor's theories.
He's the foundation for almost
all management thinking.
And while we point to
things-- Peter Drucker was
the first to do it--
we point to things
that signal to shift
from industrial work
to the knowledge economy,
we don't necessarily
point to the things
that we should probably
have not taken with us.
And so today, I
want to talk briefly
about a lot of those
different things.
I've surveyed the
Googlers that I
know about what would
be controversial but not
too controversial because
a lot of these ideas,
I find that everybody,
every innovative company
I've spoke at, is either
doing some of them
or deliberately
not doing others.
And so we'll have that
conversation, which
I think will be a lot of fun.
But I want to start
with one that's probably
not one of the things
you think about,
even though it's so vital
to our work every day.
And when you do
you think about it,
you may not have very
positive thoughts.
I want to talk about email.
And I realize I'm speaking to
the group that power, like,
half the world's email.
And so I don't want to
tell you you're wrong,
but I do want to join with
you in saying how many of you
actually hate your email inbox?
And the Gmail inbox
is one of the better
ones for dealing with the
problem of email, right?
Everybody's making note on who
raised their hand, by the way.
It's kind of funny.
Everybody's looking
around-- who hates email?
Email is an amazing tool.
It's an amazing invention.
And like most
amazing inventions,
we're using it for stuff it
was never designed to do.
How many of you use
it as a to-do list?
How many of you have ever
said the phrase, if it's not
in my inbox, it won't get done?
This was not what it was
originally intended for.
And we have this idea that--
actually, here's another one.
This is probably I'm
guilty of doing this,
and I wrote this chapter.
How many of you have
ever cleared out,
gotten to inbox
zero, and thought,
wow, I had a really
productive day today?
And then you're driving home
or you're taking the T home
and you're like, oh, actually,
I didn't do anything today
except respond to email?
So we have this theory that
it equals productivity,
but it's an inverted U.
And a lot of places are finding
that it is that exact inverted
U, that productivity can go
up through the communication
and collaboration
that it allows for,
but it can also go
dramatically down.
And one company
in particular that
fascinated me was
a French company
called Atos, a
technology company
that basically said our
productivity is not happening
the way we want it to.
And so led by their
CEO, they moved
to become a zero-email
company, zero internal email.
They created a variety of
different products and tools
in order to use
communication tools.
It's actually kind of
weird that I'm sitting here
talking about this
because when people ask me
what my favorite tool
to replace email is,
I tell them Google Wave.
[LAUGHTER]
I loved it.
Can I just say that?
Apparently, other people didn't.
But I thought it was brilliant.
So maybe this is where we
start bringing that back,
with this idea that
let's replace-- anyway,
so they moved to become
a zero-email company.
They custom-designed
a tool for them.
But a lot of other companies
are finding the same thing.
And they're using old-school
tools like the phone,
or like getting up
out of their desk
and walking over and
having a conversation.
It's fascinating.
But the idea that all of
these share is that email
has a variety of different
costs and benefits,
and the costs are beginning
to not outweigh the benefits.
So Atos moved to become
a zero-email company.
They're still moving to
become a zero-email company.
They're not quite there yet.
But they have found that
as email's going down,
a variety of positives
are happening.
Their operating
margin has increased.
Their earnings per
share have increased.
Their administrative
costs have decreased
because, again,
there's just less email
to have to sort through.
It's been a really
good thing for them,
and they've become
advocates for this sort
of zero-email lifestyle.
But honestly, how many of you
are sitting here thinking,
there's no way I can do
without my email inbox?
I like it.
I use it as my to-do
list, et cetera.
You have to see what I just saw.
I saw a bunch of people
looking down and then
holding their hand up, like
I'm embarrassed to say.
I'm with you, too.
I can't find a way
to do without it.
But there are ways that
we can put buffers on it.
There are other policies
besides zero-email.
We have limited email,
which is saying that we only
email at certain times.
So there's a dedicated
time for the email blitz,
and then you focus in
on doing the deep work.
And then there's
work hours email.
One of my favorite
corporate examples
is a company literally shuts
the server off at 6:00 PM.
So if you want to take your
laptop home with you, if you're
that person that everybody knows
who you are because you like
to email at 11:30
at night, you're
that person, that's
totally cool.
We just won't get your emails
until 8:00 AM the next morning
when the server comes back on.
What all of these have
in common is two things--
the idea of allowing people
to design their workday
in a way that works for them.
Email's an amazing
tool because it's cheap
and it's asynchronous.
It's cheap to send, and
we send a lot of it.
And it's asynchronous, so we
can send it whenever we want.
But what we don't
think about is the fact
that that means people receive
it whenever we want to send it,
which means that it's
great that you can take it
and you can use it to
design your perfect workday,
but your perfect
workday butts up
against other people's
ability to design
their perfect workday.
And we've never had
this conversation.
And you may begin to
become a champion for zero
or limited hours of work.
That's honestly not the point.
The point is we've never had
a conversation about what
is the right communication
tool for our project, what
tool for our team,
and then what are our
own individual limits?
I've talked with a lot
of different people,
mostly subordinates who report
to a manager who likes to email
at 10:00, 11:00 at night.
And even though they
know they don't have to,
there's always that
subtle pressure
that you have to
respond quickly.
And we've never had that
open and frank conversation.
So whether it's zero email,
whether it's outlawing email
entirely, or whether
it's actually
having a conversation
with your team of,
hey, what is the best way to
communicate and collaborate,
which tool do we
want to use, we can
see a lot of
positive effects just
from taking a deep look
at how we collaborate,
how we communicate.
I want to move into
one of my favorites.
This comes from HCL
Technologies based out of India,
but it's this idea of
putting customers second.
Now, I know that
the Boston location
has a variety of the
sales team, a variety
of different Googlers,
and this idea in sales
that the customer's
always right.
How many of you
have ever said that?
How you ever been the
customer and invoked that?
That's when you hear it.
Do you ever notice you always
hear it then, customer's always
right when you're the customer?
And, of course, you pull
that line and somebody says
or somebody wants to
say in their head, like,
but you're totally
wrong in this instance,
but I have pretend
that you're right?
So what is this idea of
putting customers second?
It's essentially this
idea that in order
to move customer
loyalty, you have
to look at what creates it.
It's not a goal.
It's an effect, and we have
to look at what the cause is.
Customer loyalty is created
inside of a value zone.
And to explain how
a value zone works,
let's dive deep
on the org chart.
And this isn't all that deep.
It's actually only a
few boxes and lines.
But already, you can visualize
what your own reporting
relationships have
ever looked like.
What happens in almost
every company that
has ever been started has
a founder or founders.
And as the organization scales,
generally those founders
move up through the ranks.
So naturally, as you're
teaching other people
how to do what you used to
do and you now outsource
to another person, either inside
the company or outside of it,
you want to keep that person
informed and accountable.
So most org charts work that
way-- information flows down,
accountability flows up.
The front line is accountable
to the management structures,
et cetera.
And in HCL Technologies,
Vineet Nayar, the CEO,
basically said, where's
the value being created,
because most of the
times in customer loyalty
and in customer
satisfaction, the value's
not being created at
the place that we're
holding people accountable to.
So we created what he sort
of termed the value zone,
and the value zone was
that place where people
interact with the customer.
If you're in a role that
interacts with the customer
or you have an activity that
interacts with the customer,
you are in the value zone.
You're the one
creating the value.
And so we have to think
about this information
and accountability thing as
it pertains to the value zone
because most of the time,
people in the value zone
have a divided loyalty.
The customer's
always right, but I
have to get my boss
whatever she needs.
And that creates a divided
loyalty that can cause tension.
And in some fields,
we've even seen it--
I will not ask you to
raise your hand on this one
because you may not want to--
but we've even seen situations
where in order to
please a customer,
the person who used to
be serving that customer
is thrown under the bus
so the management can
come in and solve the problem.
And what does that
do future for wanting
to continue to
create value, wanting
to continue to serve customers?
It doesn't really
help all that much.
And so what HCL
did was essentially
turn their entire org
chart upside-down.
They reversed that
accountability
and they built in
extra transparency.
What reverse the
accountability means
is they turned the org chart
upside-down and they said,
we in the management and
in the support functions
are accountable
to the value zone.
Wherever the value zone is
and as we change our business
model, wherever it goes, we need
to be accountable to it, even
to the point of creating a
customer service ticket system
for people in the value zone.
So you're serving a customer.
There is the normal sort of
customer complaint, customer
satisfaction ticket system.
They use a similar one
for I'm in the value zone
and I need something and
I've got to figure out
where it comes from.
We create a customer
support ticket.
And only the person in the value
zone who created that ticket
can close it.
And managers are actually
rated and bonused
on how well are
you serving these,
how well are you closing
out these tickets,
how well are you getting
these people what they need.
So it's this idea, again,
that accountability
rests in the value zone.
Transparency took a
real interesting form.
And in the HR world, we love
to talk about 360 feedback.
But what we usually mean by that
is manager, peers, and a couple
of hand-picked subordinates.
They went a step
further and they
said that every single person
that interacts with you
has a right to give you
feedback and has a right
to see the feedback you're
getting from other places,
extending out this idea of
transparency of feedback,
extending out this
idea of accountability
to that value zone.
And the results were
pretty incredible.
I don't think you have
to dive too deep into it,
but I want to explain why
they were so incredible.
So we have, again, this
idea that customer loyalty
is what we're striving for,
customer loyalty predicts
profitability.
And that's true--
increased market share,
increased profits are generally
tied into customer loyalty.
But customer loyalty
is an effect.
It's not a cause.
It comes after certain
other conditions are met.
Mainly, we have what we call
the service profit chain,
that customer loyalty
drives profits.
We know this.
Profits come from
customer loyalty.
Customer loyalty
is most strongly
predicted by employee
satisfaction.
That's why the food is so good.
It's most strongly predicted
by employee satisfaction,
and that's most strongly
predicted by designing your org
chart in a way to figure out
what that value zone is and put
those people first.
And by the way, you
may not be able to do
this with an entire
organization,
but you can still do it in
whatever function you serve.
Who is our customer
for our team?
Who is our customer for
our broader department?
How do we best serve
them, and how do we
make ourselves accountable
to the people that
service that customer?
And what I think
is most interesting
about this is this not an
idea that's all that new.
The service profit
chain has been around
for a really long time,
developed by professors
who basically study on
the side of the river
and on the other
side of the river.
And we've been advocating
this for a long time.
But often, people
aren't willing to take
that flip the org chart
mentality, that value zone
mentality.
And what I think HCL
provides us is an opportunity
to look at exactly
what happens when
we put that value zone first
and we say that, you know what?
The customer may
always be right.
But in order to make
the customer right,
we have to put our
own people first.
And we see this in a couple
different companies throughout,
but there are sort of these
bright stars of employees
first.
One of my favorite ones is Danny
Meyer, founder of-- how many
of you like Shake Shack?
Yes, yes, yes.
Awesome.
I was in New York
earlier this week
and was making a point to go to
every Union Square restaurant
that I could go to because
the service is amazing
and I wanted to
see it for myself.
Danny Meyer, the
founder of Union Square,
basically says this about
the service-- he sums up
the service profit chain in
a restaurant-oriented quote--
"The interests of
our own employees
must be placed directly
ahead of those of our guests
because the only way we can
consistently earn raves, win
repeat business, develop bonds
of loyalty with our guests
is to first ensure that
our own team members feel
jazzed about coming to work."
One of my other favorite
ones is from Howard Schultz
of Starbucks.
Howard Schultz, if you're
unfamiliar the Starbucks story,
you know that Howard Schultz
grew it to its notoriety
and then stepped back from the
CEO role, just a new chairman
role, and a lot
of things changed.
The changes were
subtle at first,
but you could
eventually taste them.
And so Schultz
decided to come back,
needed to turn the
stock price around.
And so one of the biggest things
that a lot of the investors
were arguing for
was, Howard, you
can cut the health
insurance plan.
You're trying to turn
the stock price around.
Nobody will blame you for that.
They'll understand
that you need to do it.
And he said, you know what?
You should probably
sell your stock
because we're not
going to do that.
Why?
Because I do not believe
that shareholder value
is sustainable if you're
not creating value
for the people who
are doing the work.
Again, we see business leaders
summarizing in their own ways
and in their own stories
a service profit chain
idea that's been around
for a really long time.
It made me most
excited to see-- this
is one of those ideas in the
book, again, that's not new,
but is an example
of what it means
to up-end business as usual.
I asked a bunch of
different people
which chapter in the
book I should talk about,
and they all said this one.
And I was not planning
on talking about it,
but I do think that
most people want
to hear either why their office
is amazing or why it's not.
So shall we dive into it?
So does anybody
know, by curiosity,
where the trend towards
open offices started?
No.
You know why?
I'll give you where
it started, but we
like to conveniently forget
that it started here.
It actually started
with Jay Chiat
and Chiat/Day advertising.
If you've ever seen the famous
1984 commercial throwing
the hammer through the
big brother screen,
that was developed by them.
And they had this
revolutionary idea
of creating the first open
office, totally nomadic office.
You got a locker
and a laptop and you
got to find your own place.
And it was a brilliant
idea in theory.
And they spent
millions of dollars
transforming their office
space, and it became a disaster.
My favorite stories
out of it is you
had people who would
arrive at work at 4:00 AM
and put their laptop
down to claim a desk
and then go back to their
car and sleep for a few hours
so they could come back and
get their favorite place.
You had people cramming
stuff into lockers
because you could have no,
like, tchotchkes whatsoever,
no personal flair,
no symbols of what
you were about in that space.
You had to have
them in your locker.
One woman couldn't
actually fit everything
she needed to do her
job in the locker.
So she became known
as the red wagon lady
because she would pull
around a little red wagon
with all of her stuff.
This was before we started
doing those crates and the bags
with wheels and
whatever, which speaking
of innovative
products, I still don't
know why it took so long to
figure out wheels on bags.
But this happened before
we figured that out,
and she became the
little red wagon lady.
What happens essentially
with the open office is this.
First of all, there's
this whole conversation
about whether or not people
are introverts and extroverts
and what they actually want.
And let me kill this
for you right now.
Introversion and extroversion
is a sliding scale,
and every single person
is different on it.
If you take a Big
Five test, you're all
going to get different numbers.
You're very rarely
placed into that box.
And so the idea that we
can find one perfect place
for you is foolish
because what you need
varies by the type
of work you do
and how you would score on that.
But even looking company-wide,
there's a balance,
there's a trade-off.
The research in
favor of open offices
will say things like, oh,
it increases collaboration,
it increases creativity,
there's these serendipitous
experiences.
And so it's for those benefits.
(WHISPERING) It helps that it's
a lot cheaper, let's just say.
But then on the
other side, we never
really talk about these studies.
The studies show
that people are more
likely to experience
stress, especially where you
sit in the open office.
Have you ever
noticed if you've got
kind of open seating, people
gravitate towards being
able to put their
back towards the wall?
That's pretty ancient
in human psychology
and human development,
this idea that we
need to be able to
see the whole room.
And we do it.
And if you're one of the
people who doesn't get that,
you're actually
experiencing more stress.
In addition, there are
increases in distraction.
Some places have
tried to mitigate this
by having this sort
of earbud code.
Two earbuds in means
don't talk to me.
One means ask.
Two means you can come up to me.
Some of you are looking
at me like you've never
heard that before.
Cool, that might be your
only takeaway from today.
That's awesome.
[LAUGHTER]
And that might have just
super helped, right?
But we've come up with
that as a response
to having to sort of cope with
the distraction factor that
happens in these offices.
And then my favorite study shows
that people in an open office
floor plan are more likely
to call in sick to work
more often, which means they're
either legitimately sick more,
or they're sick of
their open office.
In either case,
again, it comes down
to having a broader conversation
about individual differences.
And here's the challenge,
and here's the truth.
The number one factor that
affects office environment--
it's not cool offices,
it's not free food,
it's not funky design,
although I absolutely
love the T thing going
on in the elevators.
That's awesome.
But the number one factor
that affects employees,
how environment affects
employees' performance,
is perceived control--
how much control
you have to move around, to
change your office as you work
there, and to adjust it to the
needs of when you're working
with individuals, teams,
when you're doing deep work,
or when you need that
serendipity-- perceived
control.
And so it's really
not a question
of closing open offices, opening
up closed offices, et cetera,
but it's that idea
that we should
start from the
assumption of what
do I need to do to give
my team perceived control?
I've been in a lot of
really beautiful offices
where people aren't even allowed
to change the number of picture
frames on their desk.
What do you think that
does to perceived control?
And by the way, this ties in
with a huge stream of research
around the importance
of autonomy.
If we're saying we want
to give people autonomy,
we want to give
people free time,
we give people the ability to
control how they do their work
but we don't let them control
where they do their work,
then we're giving them false
promises about autonomy.
One of my favorite office
design, a lot of people
have a lot of
different terms for it.
My favorite term for it is
creating a palette of places,
creating a palette of
places where people can
exert their perceived control.
So a palette of places
looks like this--
you can go to your little
cafe in the front floor,
you can go to the long
tables where everybody
is, you can go to
your private corral,
you can book a meeting room.
Most of the time in the
service of perceived control,
there are more
seats than people.
Why?
Because, again, we want to
send the message of perceived
control, that you
are free to roam.
How many of you
feel like you know
where you need to be when you're
doing certain types of work?
But to restrict you
to just one place
limits your ability to sort of
exert that perceived control.
Some of the best offices
also organize around
what we call neighborhoods.
So there are certain
departmental neighborhoods,
and you know you're most likely
to find the colleagues you
need to find there.
But you also know that
if they're not there,
presence and performance
aren't correlated.
It doesn't mean
they're not working.
It just means they're working
sort of somewhere else.
We're putting it back in the
service of perceived control.
One more, one of my
favorites, is the perf.
It's perf season, isn't it?
Yeah, so let's talk about this.
Let's talk about the perf.
I'll give you a very,
very brief story
of a hugely innovative
company that sort of ditched
the perf altogether,
that basically threw it
in the trashcan,
and that's Adobe.
Adobe, as you know, has moved
from that sort of products
boxes on the shelf, the way you
used to have to get Photoshop,
to now Adobe Creative Cloud
and this idea of paying
a subscription.
And it triggered a
conversation about what
are the other things
we're doing legacy
on a yearly cycle or a
six-month cycle, et cetera?
And they ended up taking a
deep look at their performance
evaluations and deciding
to throw it in the trash.
Some of you may be wanting to
throw your perf in the trash
right now.
Others of you might like
it, and that's cool.
And I can tell you why both of
you feel the exact same way.
Why?
In order to tell you why, let me
first tell you what Adobe did.
They moved from the
performance appraisal system
to a system of
expectations, feedback,
and growth and development
that they called check-ins.
A check-in is any conversation--
can happen very frequently,
can happen every few
months, mostly happens
sort of on a monthly or
every six weeks basis,
could take as little
as 10 minutes,
can take as long as you want.
And it's centered around
expectations, feedback,
and growth and development.
Expectations--
setting, tracking,
reviewing what the
objectives are-- not only
what your objectives
are performance,
but what your expectations
for me are if I'm the manager.
Feedback is the same
way-- giving and receiving
ongoing feedback and coaching.
And then growth
and development--
where do you want to go?
Talking about
opportunities-- how
does your role fit into
the broader spectrum,
and where do you want to go?
What I think is great about the
check-in process is twofold,
and why it works is twofold.
First, we have perspective.
We have this idea that
giving performance appraisals
is vital, giving
feedback is vital,
to increasing performance.
And that's true, but most
places do on an annual basis
or a six-month basis.
And so most places
give that feedback.
But imagine for a minute, like
the hypothetical example I use
is imagine you're a football
team and you play every Sunday.
And you're going to
play this Sunday,
but we're not going to tell you
the score for six months, when
we do your next perf.
How likely is that you can
make course corrections easily?
Not that likely.
Feedback in the office
works the exact same way.
The more frequently you can give
that perspective of feedback,
the more frequently
you can iterate
towards better performance.
So we might normally
do an annual review.
Some places go to six months.
But these one-on-one
informal discussions
staged throughout
are hugely vital.
Now, here's why I think
this is so important.
Even though I know
it's perf season,
is that I normally only get to
have the ear of people in HR
when I make my case for
ditching performance appraisals.
But every single
person can learn
from check-ins and one-on-one
informal discussions.
If you remember nothing else
other than the earbuds thing,
maybe we can also add
on-- because by the way,
rule three of
speaking is you're not
supposed to say "if you
remember anything else,"
so I'm going to leave
you with, like, four.
So if you remember this, too--
expectations, feedback, growth
and development.
Even if you have to do the perf
every six months, if you can
every week, every two
weeks, every month,
have a conversation that
centers around those things that
is frank and honest,
then when we arrive
at the next formal
appraisal cycle,
we arrive at a conversation
that doesn't surprise anyone,
that doesn't create negotiations
over what your rank is
and what your label
is or any of that.
We just arrive at
one more conversation
in an ever-continuous
improvement
cycle of feedback, expectations,
and growth and development.
So that's performance
appraisals.
Overall, because I want to
get some time to questions.
I knew lots of people begged
me for the open office
question, the perf
question, because that's
where we are, at least
among the ones I surveyed.
Who?
You're not allowed
to know who they are.
It might affect them.
But every time that I talk
about these ideas and every time
that I talk about that
shift from industrial work
to knowledge work and every
time I tell an HR or VP that you
should ditch
performance appraisals,
I get a very similar response.
I either get love it or loathe
it, love it or loathe it.
And the loath-its always say,
we have no reason to change.
What we're doing
here is working.
Why change?
And every time I hear that,
I think about the same thing.
I think about the internal
combustion engine.
Why?
Because I'm a nerd, but
also because actually this
is one of the rare
times I can ask this
in the history of speaking.
How many of you have studied
physics as an undergrad?
Yes.
And what do you know about
the internal combustion
engine and its ability to
take gasoline and transform it
into forward motion?
It's thermodynamics.
It's very inefficient.
It is 30% efficient.
30% of the energy in
gasoline, in that fuel,
gets actually transferred
into forward motion.
The rest is lost to
heat and friction
and the rules of
thermodynamics-- 30% efficient.
And yet we experiment
with a lot of ways
to make that more efficient.
Whether that's putting
a new engine in the car
or making the car self-driving,
we continue to experiment.
The human engine
is no different.
The organization
For most of us, the fuel
running most organizations
isn't brute labor and
it's not gasoline.
It might be Red Bull,
but it's not gasoline.
It's mental energy.
And when we talk about mental
energy, one of our best metrics
for measuring efficiency is the
employee engagement metrics,
first made famous by Gallup.
But a variety of
different researchers
use a variety of
different metrics
all to try and say how
much of our whole selves
are we bringing to work, how
much of our mental energy
are we bringing to
work, how many people
inside our organization
are bringing
their whole selves to work?
And what we find is worldwide,
the number's about 18%.
It's worse than the
internal combustion engine.
In the US, it's about 30%.
And I suspect here, it's higher.
But I've never met an
organization that even takes it
to 50%, meaning that 50% of
the time or 50% of the people
feel like they bring their
whole mental energy to work.
So why is it OK to continue
to experiment with an engine,
but it's not OK to
continue to experiment
with an organization?
And that's my central
idea around this thesis.
What Frederick Taylor
did was he figured out
how to optimize for
brute force and how
to make it more efficient.
And we drug a lot of
those principles with us
from the factory to the office.
And suddenly now,
what we're doing
is working, so it's not to
continue to question it.
The leaders, the entrepreneurs,
the corporate leaders,
the researchers that I profile
in "Under New Management"
are all not satisfied
with the engine as usual.
And honestly, not every
one of these ideas
works for every
single organization.
But every single one of
them is an experiment.
It's a moonshot.
It's an attempt to
raise this number.
And I'm not an optimist.
I don't believe that
we can get to 100%
on the whatever is slightly less
depressed than an optimist--
I'm not a pessimist, but
whatever is slightly less
depressed than an optimist.
I don't believe that we can
get that number up to 100%.
But, god, if we
could get it to 50%?
If most Americans had
a coin-flip chance
of finding a job that engaged
them, that'd be amazing.
I have two sons.
They're four and they're two.
And this is honestly
what drives me
around this, is that
I'm thinking about 15,
20 years from now
where they go to work,
can we change the engine
and get it to the point
where they have a coin-flip
chance of being engaged?
Even an organization
that lots of people
like to write about, like
Google, that you know people
who are not bringing their
whole selves to work,
can we experiment?
Can we change these ideas?
Can we play around with
new modes and methods
to raise this number up?
Great leaders don't
innovate the product,
they innovate the factory.
So let's turn our
conversation to how
we can innovate
the factory and let
that be the huge
surge that proceeds
a wave of product innovation.
We can get there.
We can.
It just takes continued
experimentation.
Great leaders don't
innovate the product,
they innovate the factory.
That said, what questions
do you have about how
we innovate a factory?
AUDIENCE: So on the
open floor plan issue,
the book "Making Software"
cites sociology studies that
were put together on open
offices versus closed offices.
And it basically came down to if
the task was an individual sort
of task, closed doors help.
If it's a collaborative task,
then having open space helps.
Why do you cite it as just
individual preference?
DAVID BURKUS: So I think
it's a combination of things.
I definitely think
it's the type of work.
And most people, I
don't think you can say
do one type of work one way.
So I think there's a human
psychology piece, which
is individual
differences, and then I
think there's the type
of work that people do.
But then even if you combine,
like you times those two
by each other and
you have a factor
a variety of different
things-- like I,
because my training's in
organizational psychology,
tend to lean towards that side.
But the type of work being
done also influences it.
But there's a confounding factor
of how an individual likes
to do that type of work.
So I'm a writer.
And I know people that
love to write in solace,
and I know people that will
deliberately go to a cafe
in order to write with all
sorts of noise around them--
same type of work, but
the individual difference
is sort of also a
confounding factor in it.
AUDIENCE: Should we focus more
on what environment fails less
for the opposite task
when it comes up,
and not the obvious fact
that open offices are better
for collaboration and
closed offices are
better for independent work?
DAVID BURKUS: I side on the side
of perceived control, like I
think when we need to
think about how we design
a whole place, we need
to know that there's
a ton of different types of
work and a ton of different ways
that people like to
do that type of work.
And so that palette
of places approach
gives perceived control
over to the person.
It gives them the
individual idea.
That does mean we have to have
a conversation about how you can
know whether or not you're being
productive because sometimes we
might feel like we're
being productive,
but we're actually being
distracted often-- see email
as an example.
But I think, again,
it comes down
to that idea of
designing the place that
works for a variety
of different means
and then just setting people
free to kind of figure it out.
AUDIENCE: So performance--
DAVID BURKUS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: We all hate it.
And one of the reasons--
DAVID BURKUS:
Performance appraisals.
AUDIENCE: Performance
appraisals,
not high performance.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID BURKUS: I
was going to say,
I think I'm in the wrong
room if that's the case.
AUDIENCE: Perf, perf.
DAVID BURKUS: Perf, right.
AUDIENCE: We all hate it.
And one of the
reasons I hate it is--
DAVID BURKUS: You're saying
this on camera, by the way.
I was deliberately not asking
questions about this one.
AUDIENCE: That's fine.
DAVID BURKUS: No, no.
Go for it.
AUDIENCE: There's a
tension between being
honest and playing the game.
So when I'm talking
to my boss, I really
don't want to tell
him, you know what?
Monday and Tuesday this
week, I got nothing done.
And I'm in a bad mood,
and I hate my co-worker.
And by the way, you made
a stupid mistake yesterday
at the meeting, which completely
derailed, blah, blah, blah.
Do I really want to
say things like that?
And how is the continuous
process any better?
My boss is not my therapist, and
can influence my career, right?
DAVID BURKUS: Right.
AUDIENCE: So how do you
deal with this tension
between honesty and a
productive feedback?
DAVID BURKUS: So the first
challenge is, other than--
and actually, your comment
reminded me of that scene
in "Office Space" where he
describes what he does and he's
like, I get to work
and I just kind
of stare at the wall
for, like, 15 minutes.
So you don't want to admit
that, although he admits it
and he gets promoted.
The things that you said my boss
doesn't kind of want to hear,
part of him doesn't
want to hear it.
Part of him needs to hear it,
or part of her needs to hear it.
And so it begins from that
place of understanding
that these sessions aren't
necessary be used to label.
They're to be used to
have that conversation,
and it takes an
openness at that level
to actually hear that feedback.
Now, for some people,
it takes a lot
of training to get
them to that point
where they're sort of open
to hearing that feedback.
One of my writer friends
say teaching people
how to hug their haters so they
can actually learn and grow
from it.
The biggest thing is the lack
of formality of the event.
I think what causes
a lot of the stress
and the playing the
game that you said
is that it eventually gets
documented, goes in a file.
And so it's very
careful about what
goes in the file, what
doesn't go in the file.
And a lot of times, it'll take
some time to ramp up to it.
But when you can
sort of actually
get people to believe
that, no, we're
having an open, honest
conversation, none of it's
getting written
down, none of it's
going in a file,
let's just talk,
gradually people start
to lower their guard.
It will not happen
the first time.
Like I said, I'm one
step below optimism.
Whatever is one step less
pessimistic than an optimist,
I'm that.
So it won't happen right away.
But the hope is that
if we shift to that
and we really get people
to believe that these are
informal conversations,
they're not going in the file,
they're just about how do
we get you what you need,
then we can actually
move towards.
AUDIENCE: As a fairly quick
followup, we do have procedures
here where you can ask
for advice from someone
outside your management
chain, which I haven't taken
advantage of enough, I'm sure.
Does it make sense
for the same person
to be managing you day-to-day
and evaluating you and getting
honest feedback?
Are those all the same role?
DAVID BURKUS: It varies a lot.
So one of the
chapters that, which
I didn't go into it today, but
one of the chapters we have
in "Under New Management"
is about the companies that
really do fire the manager.
And then there are
other companies
to try and do it and find
that they need a management
structure.
And it comes down to there are
certain roles in management
in every organization
based on the type of work
and the culture can decide
who best does those role.
And sometimes, they decide
the team works it better,
the peers do it better.
Sometimes they decide that
management does it better.
But you're absolutely right.
One of the things I love
about in the accountability
piece around doing
360 for management
was that idea that everybody
who's interacted your
throughout the year
has that ability
to leave you feedback, which
I think it's hard, again,
do that in an
informal conversation.
That said, the hope
and the assumption
is that your manager and
the people on your team,
the people who work
closest with you,
are the most invested in
your long-term success,
your long-term performance.
And so because of that
emotional investment,
they're probably the best one to
have the informal conversation
with.
But you're absolutely
right, most of us
work with people who are
not technically on our team,
and we still collaborate
with them at times.
And that data isn't
really getting
captured in a very good system.
Some of that's the nature
of the beast, and some of it
is we shouldn't
allow it to happen.
We should spread it out.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
DAVID BURKUS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So thank you for the talks.
So staying on this
topic, so getting rid
of performance
evaluations-- I want
to look under the cover
of that a little bit.
DAVID BURKUS: Everybody
wants-- it's the right season.
AUDIENCE: It reminds
me of politicians
who say that we should get
rid of the Internal Revenue
Service.
That sound
superficially appealing.
But at the end of the day, those
things still need to get done.
And so in my past many
years of being a manager,
I've come to realize that
a lot of this process
is not about torturing
the individual employees.
It's really about forcing
managers to do the right thing.
So without things like
curves, for example,
you'll have lazy managers who
give everyone the same score.
They're conflict-averse, or
they'll just give the bennies
to their friends or whatever.
And so we need sort of
the managers' managers
kind of structure to make
sure the right things happen.
And that has to happen,
anyway, I think.
So to me, it feels
like a false dichotomy.
It's not really get rid of
the performance evaluation,
it's really you need both.
A good manager should be
doing those other things
all the time, anyway.
But you still need
a formal process.
You still need a process
to compare people
in an objective way.
You still need to decide
about promotions and raises
and who was not performing
and so on and so forth.
DAVID BURKUS: No.
And so in general, I agree.
So there's a teeny bit of
hyperbole to get rid of the IRS
because it's always if
deep down, we're going
to replace it with something.
Or it's not, and
hopefully that person
doesn't get a
plurality of the vote.
But so it's always a
situation where you're
replacing it with something.
In this case, I love
the Adobe example
because what they
replaced it with
was we're going to get
rid of this formal system.
And one of the things I
sort of didn't roll out
is we're going to replace
it with coaching managers
and have these
conversations, when
to have these conversations,
a lot of different training
on it.
And that can only really
happen in a culture,
too, that reinforces
those ideas--
that feedback, that
evaluation, that
keeping track of who
needs what in order to be
ready for promotions, et
cetera, is hugely important.
So you can't just sort of
strip it, you're absolutely.
What you can do is train
that informal system.
But it does take-- and honestly,
it takes a lot more work
than just saying, well,
we do perf for six months,
we do an annual
review, whatever.
That's the way to accomplish
the objective with less
energy than does this?
But the ROI on this is
significantly better,
I believe, because you're
training people on how to do it
and you're giving
it more frequently.
AUDIENCE: We can
certainly imagine
it's the throwing the baby
out with the bathwater
kind of thing, where you go too
far, basically, and have to--
DAVID BURKUS: Absolutely.
No.
And in general, I
think that's what
the conversation I see in
management that hasn't happened
that should is that, as I
said before, we drug a lot
of Taylorism with us from
the factory to the office.
And we never really had a
conversation about what parts
of it we should use and
what parts we shouldn't.
And as the nature of work
evolves, a lot of it's
going to fall by the wayside.
But that doesn't mean we
have to stop doing it.
It means we have to say, what
does management look like?
How do we innovate the factory?
We can't just let
it be free-range,
but how do we innovate?
What do we replace it with?
Absolutely.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So to expand upon
that, in addition
to what does
management look like,
I think you said every
time you present it
to HR, the responses--
DAVID BURKUS: Well,
love it or loathe it.
But yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So what would your vision
be for a sort of future HR,
because I feel like we've had
lots of innovation and lots
of different industries,
but HR is pretty consistent.
And at Google, it's a
little bit different.
But very few HR have
come from actually
doing the work in
the individual roles,
and yet they're
part of evaluating.
So how does that need
to evolve to support?
And what does that look like
at Adobe, if you can share?
DAVID BURKUS: So you actually
pointed to my favorite thing
that has to change right off the
bat, which is the idea that--
twofold-- the idea that you can
be in HR or People Operations
without having
been anywhere else,
but also that you can get
very high in the organization
in most companies all the
way up to the senior levels
without ever having
done a stint in HR.
And I think we need to see
that as one other path or one
other stop in a
path that is vital
not just for people to
start somewhere else
and migrate to HR,
but also if they're
wanting to migrate up
through the organization,
to do it through
HR for that reason.
I think there needs
to be a broader
conversation about the type
of work, what that requires.
And my hope is that that would
change the culture for most
organizations.
And true or not true to
that value zone concept,
for most organizations,
HR or People Operations
is an overhead.
It doesn't really
create that value.
Yet at the same
time, if our people
create all of our value, then
the conversations about what
are the developmental
needs of our people, who
are the ones that are
performing stronger than others,
those things are vital to
continue to create value.
So my hope is-- HR will
use the term "we hope
we have a seat at the table."
But I also hope they
get up from their table
and go and sit down at other
departmental tables, too.
I think we start
there, if we can.
Thank you.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Different subject-- I'm
interested very much
in your thoughts
on Managed by Q. I
don't know whether you'd
be willing to say too much
about a particular company.
But in their case, it
seems quite unique.
And also, I think it's probably
the most radical attempt
out there to innovate the
factory that's going on.
And I'm wondering if you think
they can possibly succeed
and whether they
can possibly have
an impact on the whole outsource
service industry that we have.
I assume you know what
I'm talking about.
DAVID BURKUS: So Managed by
Queue as in, like, Q-U-E--
AUDIENCE: No, Q. Q as in--
DAVID BURKUS: As in the letter?
AUDIENCE: Q, the James Bond
guy who did all that stuff.
Managed by Q. Sorry to
have to explain this.
I thought you of all people
would be totally up on this.
But Managed by Q
is a company that
is in the service industry.
And instead of having the model
of having the absolute lowest
wages, benefits,
whatever out there,
they are competing with
cleaning companies, companies
that go into offices in
cities and do cleaning
and that have the absolute
lowest wages, benefits, hire
the most immigrants, the
whole thing-- these guys have
a totally different model.
They pay their employees well.
They have health insurance.
More importantly, they
have more management type
responsibilities.
And they're encouraged
to interact directly
with their clients
in the building.
It's a totally different
model of how a company can
do a service industry.
If they succeed, which is
really the big question,
that model threatens to
completely revolutionize
the whole model of how
service industries in general
have developed in this country.
This is a massively important
thing that's going on here.
Sorry.
DAVID BURKUS: No, no know, no.
So admittedly, this is
me being the [INAUDIBLE]
of psychologists that always
love to see a lot of data.
Admittedly, my jury's
still out on that.
There are things to what you
just described that I really
like, especially the idea of the
interaction with client piece
and the idea, again,
of taking care
of people who are
in that value zone
and knowing that that's
where value is created.
I tend to reserve
judgment, passing judgment,
on things like that because
I'm not good at forecasting.
I'm trained as a
psychologist, so I'm
only good at looking
back and going,
huh, this seems to predict this.
So often, I get a
similar question often
around, like, Holacracy
and those sort of things.
And I just think, like,
let's ride this one out.
I can see arguments for
it, arguments against it.
And as it scales,
I think we'll have
a better idea of where we can
go and forming an opinion on it.
I know that's sort
of a non-answer.
And I know it's
political season,
so we're all attuned
to non-answers.
But I honestly prefer
to keep my jury still
deliberating on that one.
AUDIENCE: It's OK.
It's definitely an experiment.
DAVID BURKUS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The guy behind
it is totally seriously.
He has a profit model
that he'll explain
to you and the whole thing.
Whether it will succeed,
I don't really know.
But it's gotten a lot
of press recently,
so I'm going to
definitely look into it.
DAVID BURKUS: And I'll say one
other thing towards that, which
is that there's a tendency
among a lot of different people
to say this is the
way to do it, we're
going to write the operating
system for management,
et cetera.
And the challenge
is that in general,
as the nature of work
changes, every organization
needs something slightly
different from management.
And then as the people who come
into the organization change,
we have, again, that
individual differences
versus the type of
work thing, the needs
of every individual
management change.
I know a lot of
different people who
have promoted their model of
this is how we should do it.
I don't have a four-box
model and that type of thing.
I just have here are the
ideas and the experiments.
But every company has to
wrestle with how we apply this.
I think maybe we have
time for about one more.
I'm getting the time
of day notifications.
AUDIENCE: Great, thanks.
DAVID BURKUS: And we
can chat afterwards.
I definitely want to chat.
AUDIENCE: Bruce [INAUDIBLE],
and I work in design.
And I have a sort of--
it's a two-question,
so you could pick up either
one or depending on the time.
But there's a conventional
systems question
of how the pieces fit
together, and then
maybe an unconventional
question.
The conventional part
is I was curious,
have you thought about
the way different kinds
of managements intersect?
So there's the people management
that you're describing--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Project, product, operations.
And then the second
part of the question
is what about if there's AI?
So if you submit jobs
out to Mechanical Turk,
it could be a person,
it could be a computer.
Does this mean we
should be finding ways
to use the techniques that
would work also for computers?
Or does it mean
that we should find
ways to take what
we've learned and apply
it people, or any thoughts?
DAVID BURKUS: Wow.
I knew I'd get
awesome questions.
So admittedly, the
second one, I'm
probably going to be thinking
about the entire plane ride
home.
AUDIENCE: Nice.
DAVID BURKUS: So then I
can't say I'll email you
because-- but--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] was here
two weeks ago in Cambridge,
and they have Amy, or Angie.
Apparently people only ask Amy
to set up their lunch dates.
But the founder
said that people are
treating the AI like a person.
So it would be, Amy, would
you please set this up?
And so will it be important
to review the software?
If we were to issue
review of the software,
would that also then affect
the way that we review people?
Are we treating
people like machines,
and because we're treating
machine like people?
DAVID BURKUS: So
this is me being
my favoritist towards humans.
I would imagine as we're
designing an AI system,
we're going to try and
design it most like ours.
And then whoever's designing it
gets to fix a few of our flaws.
And that's the thing that we
honestly have to wrestle with.
So to answer the first question
around people, operation,
project, management-- as
we shift from physical work
to idea work, as everything
that can be outsourced
to lesser intelligent, robotics,
Ken is given to them-- not AI
but just to straight
robotics, because that's all
outsourced-- our roles become
more and more about ideas.
And ideas are still
generated, at least right now,
by our brains.
And so I think we start
there and we tie it back
to people because even in a
project management system,
a lot of the contextual
variables are on people.
So in my own-- I don't
want to give too much
into my own things,
but I'm actually
dealing with an operations
management issue
now that was a result
of still a person.
So I think we start there.
On the broader AI
question, I think
it'd be really interesting to
see how much AI psychology--
this will be a
department in the future,
it's like AI psychology--
how much that mind mirrors
our own mind and what
quirks made the transfer
and what quirks we fixed for.
And then we have to, again,
think about how do we
innovate the factory for that?
That's fascinating, though.
You just ruined my
in-flight movie.
But that's OK.
I really do believe
because we're modeling it
after the human mind, but
trying to make it better,
so we'll keep some things,
we'll drop other things,
and then we've got to do
the study all over again.
Yeah, fascinating.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
DAVID BURKUS: Well,
in the meantime,
thank you all so
much for having me.
I knew I would get questions
that, again, would ruin
my in-flight movie
because I'll be thinking
about them the whole time.
So that's awesome.
I'll linger and chat if there
are any further questions.
If there are not, great leaders
don't innovate the product,
they innovate the factory.
And whether these ideas
resonated with you or they just
sparked new ones
because you're thinking
about innovate the
factory of your team,
of your workplace,
et cetera, I hope
we keep that conversation
going and keep
thinking about how we
innovate our new idea factory.
So thank you all so
much for having me.
[APPLAUSE]